Chronicle is arguably valerent goat
which allows Chronicle to move in from
behind that's one kill taken one out of
the equation a kill onto Mr the end of
it 10 seconds he needs a kill needs to
look to the other side it's a t
Chronicle he's a monster he's a de and
if you watched valerant Champions then
you might have seen him rocking a fairly
interesting Mouse this is fanatic's new
mouse well kind of oh what is it then
it's a fanatic branded orange lambu
Thorn but unlike the original version
this one has their logo slapped on on to
it of course it comes with extra skates
and grips but it also ships with a 4K
dongle so you can bump up those polling
rates it's a solid Ergo Mouse with a
similar shape to the Razer Death Adder
V3 Pro but just a tad smaller and about
10 G lighter I can't guarantee that
you'll start lifting trophies like
Chronicle if you buy one but for 100 us
it's pretty sick at least if you can get
your hands on one